Stop calling yourself an expert
if you don't know what an expert is.
Let me explain.
So basically,
Americans have started moving to other countries,
like Mexico,
Thailand, Vietnam, etc.
And instead of calling themselves immigrants
like they should be calling themselves,
they're calling themselves experts.
If you have to move to another country
because you can't afford to live in the US,
you are literally an economic refugee
and economic migrant.
You're not a expert.
And it's funny,
because refugee is literally a synonym for expat.
And then they always make the counter argument, oh,
well, an expat is somebody that moves somewhere else
temporarily.
Okay, so you're an economic refugee and economic migrant.
If I go to Canada right now
with plans to work and come back to Mexico,
they're not gonna call me an expat.
They're gonna call me an economic migrant.
Refugee or an immigrant,
whatever, you know,
they're not gonna call me an expat.
If something happens to you while you're in Mexico,
you're not gonna go to expat services.
You're gonna go to immigration services.
There's no office for expats.
If that's the case,
every Mexican working in the US
with plans on coming back to Mexico is an expert.
Then I don't know how to tell you this,
but you're an immigrant.
You're a migrant.
You're an economic refugee and economic migrant.
It doesn't matter how
and what fancy words you try to use.
Oh, I'm an expert. No,
you're an immigrant.
But Anyways,
let me know what you guys think.